the search continues for families in
need of baby formula you may remember
the massive shortage from earlier this
year with manufacturers like Abbott
nutrition recalling three types of
infant formula Similac elementum and
Ella care now in the middle of the
holiday season some are still having a
tough time finding Supply Madison
Kimbrough joins us live in The Newsroom
tonight with more on this Madison
yeah while the FDA officials say formula
supplies are improving more is needed to
get to its customers as families are
still struggling to find products going
into the new year
I would honestly go to the the Sam's
Club website the Costco websites the
um Target and I would
um just keep checking throughout and I
would buy it just quickly right away
that way I wasn't going from store to
store Cindy Riley a local here in Las
Vegas and mom of three knows the
struggle when it comes to finding baby
formula a problem many families faced
earlier this year when popular
manufacturer Abbott nutrition had some
of their formula recalled after many
infants came down with bacterial
infections after consuming it this in
turn caused a massive shortage and while
supply has increased since then families
Across the Nation are still having
trouble finding what they need U.S
census data shows that adults in more
than a third of households with infants
who use formula still have trouble
finding it as of mid-november I would
buy for myself and a friend who was on
formula at the same time
so I actually ended up giving her quite
a bit it seems like the the purple the
purple
um Enfamil is still difficult for people
to find that was my first one to go many
believe this shortage is due to customer
stockpiling for fear of running out
again while inflation and the effects of
the supply chain continue to be the main
contributor Henderson Women's Care
Doctor Douglas tanita says he handles a
lot of prenatal care and for those
expecting mothers this shortage is a
major concern and a lack of resources
has been apparent in the last couple
months we do have the formula reps that
do come into our office and they'll
leave us formula uh usually we're giving
samples to our patients and then you
know the idea is obviously these
companies want to Market to these you
know soon to be moms and then they have
the formula but I haven't seen a rep
come by our office for a while
and there's no telling how long this new
baby formula shortage could last but the
FDA and manufacturers are working to
increase Supply now as for resources
social media can be a great tool like on
Facebook LV baby formula locator that's
a group that you can join to help find
product also talking to your
pediatrician about what the best options
are for your infant reporting live in
The Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now